let's continue on with a unique st
patrick's day recipe of irish nachos
thanks to chef jeff jackson from smith's
food and drug the sponsors of this
segment check it out
hello everybody i'm chef jeff from
smith's okay i've got my green on st
patrick's day is coming up today i'm
going to give you a recipe that kind of
goes a little bit off of the norm for
for st patrick's day you know the
traditionals like corned beef and
cabbage or irish stew while those are
all good they're kind of boring today's
recipe is not but we're going to be
using some of those similar flavors
we're making irish nachos and we have
some corned beef and some bacon and
potatoes cheese all those lovely things
let's get right to it super easy to make
kind of fun okay so we need to cut our
potatoes into quarter inch discs like
this you can do it with a mandolin like
i have here it's even green for the for
the holiday as well
i do it that way just because it's a
little easier than knife and it gets a
little bit more consistent cut but when
you're using mandolin be careful not to
put your fingers down there so just be
very thoughtful of that while you're
doing this
and hopefully
by the time you get close you're going
to put your hand fingers away so you
don't cut your fingers like so
a little safer just use a knife but i
like the consistency i get through
through here so now i've got my chips
for my nachos but i need to cook these
first and i need to get them nice and
toasty so i'm going to use you some ghee
this is just clarified butter you could
use that oil if you wanted as well or
just melted butter
any oil would work there and then i'm
going to season it with salt pepper
thyme garlic powder and then i'm just
going to go ahead and mix this up my
oven is preheated to 450 so it's a hot
oven
and then once i get these mixed up then
i'm going to put them on a sheet pan and
then they're going to go in the oven and
bake for 20 minutes on one side flip
them 20 minutes on the other so try and
get them as best you can on a single
layer that way they cook it really nice
and even
and then we're going to get these in the
oven and then
we're going to turn them into nachos
here in just a few minutes okay so that
looks good
get these in the oven 450
20 minutes flip them 20 minutes
okay magic of tv my potatoes are done 20
minutes on either side 450 degrees they
get nice and brown and crispy so these
are our chips for our nachos so now i'm
going to arrange them in a cast iron
dish or an um
just some oven safe pan of some sort
that you have that is going to be best
so i'm just going to layer them in this
pan like so
okay so i've
neatly organized them in my pan now i'm
going to add something this is some
corned beef that i got from the deli you
don't have to cook corned beef just get
it from the deli and have them slice it
thick so just put that corned beef on
there for that familiar balance or
valentine's day st patrick's day flavor
and then we're gonna add some bacon of
course because it's potatoes and
potatoes love bacon and then we have
some irish cheddar irish cheddar that
we're gonna put on top we're gonna put
this in the under the broiler
just for a couple of seconds
okay so they're all melty and looking
delicious we're gonna finish with some
pico de gallo not very irish but you get
the the idea some green onions some
cilantro we're gonna finish with some
sour cream
you can find all these ingredients your
local smiths thank you so much for
watching thank you for shopping and we
will see you all next time bye everybody
thank you again to smith's food and drug
for sponsoring this segment for more
information and recipes visit their
website smithsfoodanddrug.com